what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on with Aquaman all
right here's one of the cool things
because Aquaman again like with this
whole situation unfolding the way that
it did which is to say King Wrath
basically orchestrating the ousting of
Aquaman as the king of Atlantis and then
Aquaman basically taking up the
leadership role of the undercurrent this
kind of revolutionary faction looking to
overthrow quorum wrath and then kind of
go from there one of the things bear in
mind
Aquaman doesn't want to be king it's one
of the things we talked about in the
last video that Aquaman does not want to
be king and so the result is that he's
kind of in this precarious situation but
the important thing that also goes on
here is you've got Arthur curry who
basically shows up when there's like a
handful of these callings that go on now
again this is the intensity of quorum
wrath basically running Atlantis with an
iron fist he reminds me a lot of
Voldemort for might the Harry Potter
books which is to say he's a guy who
basically says pure Bloods are the only
way to go like you need tried and true
dictators and what he's been doing is
sending the drift in remember the drift
is the Special Forces of Atlantis he's
been sitting the drift in and basically
saying look your job is to eliminate
anybody who is not deemed to be pure
which is to say anybody who has a
mutation or anything like that
anyone who's not a tried-and-true
Atlantean and so again it's pretty
hardcore and so where he shows up here
he confronts us some members of the
drift and basically manages to overcome
all of them and turn like that leads to
the freeing of these various you know
members of Atlantis who had been taken
captive with the intention of executing
them the problem with this is that as
Aquaman begins to talk to volcko one of
the things that volcko does is he says
look you are a guy who's basically in a
position is the return to the role of
being king of Atlantis
but Aquaman doesn't want to be king and
it's one of the things that volcko
argues with him about now the other half
of this is remembered Aquaman doesn't
really trust him and it makes sense
because volcko was the one who
essentially orchestrated the throne of
Atlantis fight which led to like the
Atlantean Kingdom more or less attacking
the surface world so I mean is it was
really him who kind of orchestrated all
that stuff so while he is a member what
has been an elder in Atlantis for a long
time and does bring a lot to the table
Aquaman doesn't truly know if what
volcko is doing is for the benefit of
Atlantis or if what volcko doing is for
his own agenda his own scheme and so as
one of these huge arguments that goes on
between the two of them while the two of
them are sort of arguing against each
other one of the things of volcko says
is that where Aquaman kind of responds
by saying look the undercurrents not
strong enough to mount a full revolution
volcko stances but you're not doing
anything of any significance you're
freeing a few people here and there but
you haven't done anything that's made
you a credible threat to quorum wrath
this point you're a nuisance so while
you're trying to build up your base no
one sees you as anyone who's credible
enough to be successful and so they're
not actually going to join your
revolution and it's cool here because it
kind of puts Aquaman in a very
precarious situation on one hand he
wants to free Atlantis but on the other
hand he's sort of hesitant to do what
needs to be done to free Atlantis it's
one of these scenarios where if you're
winning a war you can't take the high
ground the high ground is reserved for
those who are looking to lose the war
you have to become as bad as the people
that you're fighting against otherwise
what's the point of fighting and so it's
kind of a wake up call
really for Aquaman as a character now
again picking up with with Mother Sathya
the head of the the widowhood again
these are basically the magic wielders
in in Atlantis and they're playing their
own game of Thrones and that's why this
is so awesome because the way the Dan
Abnett writes this it's almost like a
movie but there's like a ton of pieces
that work here Aquaman's part of the
undercurrent he's leading a rebel
faction trying to overthrow a quorum RAF
quorum Rath is launching his own schemes
and mecha nations and you've got the
widowhood which are basically trying to
position themselves so that if Aquaman
doesn't want to be king then they can
position their own person instead they
can put Mara in as queen and have her be
the one to run the show now Ondine is
kind of like they're their inside person
the only person that really knows what's
going on with Ondine of course is volcko
and Aquaman is totally unaware and some
others to Tia's response is look if what
you've overheard has led you to believe
that Aquaman will not take the throne
once he wins then your job is to make
him do whatever he needs to do because
again the whole idea of volcko is attack
the crown of Atlantis but Aquaman's
responses look the amount of forces they
would send after us would be
astronomical it'd be their entire army
like Horwath would send everyone out
there to stop us and we'd be slaughtered
because our numbers just aren't large
enough and so with Ondine reporting this
batch is Satya
so Tia's response is say what you need
to do whatever you have to but get him
to bring down that shield and that's
when Ondine pipes up and says let's use
the armies of the various gangs now this
is a very very huge risk this is a very
big gamble because it's one of these
things where the loyalty of mercenaries
can be bought and paid for it which
means their loyalty is to the highest
bidder and if you're not the highest
bidder they're gonna take you out if
somebody else comes along and pays them
more to do so and so that's really kind
of the situation that Aquaman's in he
ends up going to the ninth tried and at
this point the entire place is a war
zone and so where Aquaman basically
shows out and kind of confronts king
shark his stance is look you're the one
who's trying to take over the show right
I mean King shark is a long-standing
villain in DC he's not a huge figure
here so
have to go super in-depth I just know
that he's just kind of a guy that's
there at least in the context of this
story but we're Holcomb and shows that
my says look I want your all's loyalty I
want you guys to fight on my behalf
King shark immediately turns against him
his stance is we take care of our own
you are Aquaman you're Arthur curry you
rule from on high you never cared about
us before there's no reason for you to
care about us now and it makes perfect
sense that's how a lot of these people
view Aquaman like a lot of these groups
they see him as you never wanted
anything from us until you write your
most desperate and then now you need us
know you can go away and so it's kind of
a cool little thing here because the
response that that Aquaman gives is yes
but this is the fate of all of Atlantis
here and again King shark kind of
responds I don't care if the ninth tried
is always governed itself and it's
always taken care of itself and it'll
take care of itself from here on out
we'll do whatever we need to do now
while all this goes on you end up having
dolphin again basically one of these
mutants has essentially gone grown
smitten with with Aquaman who's watching
the whole thing unfold but as she's kind
of looking around somebody starts
calling out for help and when she goes
to respond we end up finding out that
Mira's basically dying now again those
you guys who were just catching up with
us here mirror of course being the the
wife-to-be of Aquaman his fiancee at the
moment when Aquaman was believed to have
been dead
she took off to the surface under the
belief that her husband or her fiance
was essentially gone and then grieved
his vest she cut what ended up happening
was when she learned Aquaman was alive
she ultimately came back of course she
was able to pierce the thought of the
the crown of thorns using kind of a
half-cocked device which basically cost
her her ability to breathe underwater
due to exposure to the magic of the
crown of Atlantis itself and so when
that happened she's basically like an
air breather stuck underwater so they
have an oxygen tank hooked up to her but
it's running out of air and so you end
up having dolphin who kind of sends out
one of her bioluminescence 'as
essentially for the intention of blind
of blinding the guy who's there and then
killing Mara but when Aquaman picks up
on it he immediately races over only to
find Mara is there now this is kind of a
big moment where Aquaman frees Mara from
this prison she's kind of been held in
dolphins watching the whole thing unfold
and the way this plays out
dolphins none too happy about the fact
that Aquaman's found his fiancee she's
competition and and as any guy with any
real game will tell you women get fierce
when it comes to competition it's pretty
intense but the fact remains here that
of course Ondine is watching the whole
thing unfold and this is where really
like the game of thrones esque situation
begins to come into play because on dean
says look I can give you what you need
in order to save
follow me and I'll take you to where
that where you need to go of course this
goes to the tower of the widowhood and
this is when the widowhood makes their
move and that's the important thing
they're opportunists and again this is
like every government ever right like
there are those who just kind of sit and
wait they just sit in the shadows and
they're biding their time and they're
waiting for their chance to seize an
opportunity and when there's blood in
the water the Sharks will come and in
this instance they're looking for a way
to basically take down the the crown of
thorns but they're also looking for a
way to keep Mara alive and so the
widowhood basically looks to Aquaman and
says well we can save Mara early right
now she's safe but she needs to recover
on the surface well that's when the
problem comes into play well you've got
the crown the crown of thorns it's been
kind of Lance's all around this whole
thing and the response is well then you
have to take it out like you don't have
a choice you've got to take the whole
thing down they're kind of forcing his
hand here and that's what the widow hood
was looking for it wasn't enough to be
able to kind of like try to bide and try
to bribe and try to convince Aquaman of
what he needed to do what they needed
was some way to force him into a corner
some way to basically say this is the
only option this is your only way out
and they know he loves Mara enough that
he'll do it he'll do whatever it takes
to save her life and that's exactly what
happens he basically says fun you know
now again the question of Aquaman is why
are you even doing this in the first
place and that's when Satya in them say
we want to put mera and power so Tia in
them look at the situation they say okay
look we obviously screwed up by putting
quorum wrath empowered we obviously made
a mistake here but you don't want to be
king and you were a poor King anyway
because you were too progressive but
mera is a person who understands duty
she understands what it means to control
a particular situation she knows what it
means to put duty before matters of the
heart even if you can't Atlantis has to
have a ruler Atlantis has to have
somebody running the show and if you
won't do it then mera will and when
Aquaman is kind of against that when he
kind of argues against that city is like
you know it's the right thing to do and
so Aquaman races over to mera basically
starts talking to her about the whole
thing and the stance of mera is Satya is
not wrong
Atlantis needs a ruler and if I can be
that ruler then I will be that ruler the
problem here the question that comes
into play is what happens if Mira has to
choose between Aquaman or Atlantis and
that's the question that Aquaman poses
not directly but he poses it in kind of
a sense of asking does this mean that
we're basically done and in mears
responses well no I mean we're not done
you know we'll make a life together but
it's really kind of taking this question
and putting it on the back burner and
saying basically we'll cross this bridge
once we
get there and so Aquaman basically
accepts the choice of mirror and says if
this is what has to happen then I will
rule by your stead as not even really a
king yeah I guess really kind of as a
king but you know I would rule by your
set is more like a figurehead and so in
turn he travels back to King shark and
king shark stance is the same look we
are not going to fight alongside you
unless you give someone worthy to fight
alongside and so the response of Aquaman
is but I wouldn't be your king the
person that ruled that would rule this
place would be Meera and while that does
appease king shark in the end he still
says no why because the numbers are not
on their side and this is really Dan
admits way of showing how people
perceive Aquaman when he's no longer
king when he's no longer a guy that
rules on rules Atlanta's with absolute
authority no one trusts him no one
believes it he's truly capable but more
so than that when it comes to someone
like King shark and when you're ruling
you know an entire section it really
does come down to a numbers game that
we're all bands talking about fighting
for the preservation of Atlantis king
sharks fighting for the preservation of
the ninth tribe as the Wits dance is if
we send our guys with you they're
probably gonna die they're probably
gonna get slaughtered and then what's
gonna happen to the to the ninth tribe
who's gonna protect it who's gonna be
there to keep those people safe and so
it's very much kind of looking at the
situation for what it is and then simply
saying that's not gonna happen we're not
gonna fight alongside you and so they're
basically left to their own devices and
so what ends up happening here is
Aquaman goes back to the undercurrent
goes back to the rebel rial to the rebel
faction and says look I'm gonna go
attach this forcefield come with me if
you want stay here if you choose to you
will not be looked at with shame if you
stay behind you're doing what's best for
the undercurrent you're basically
sacrificing this battle in the hopes
that you can win the war but the stance
of Aquaman is I'm launching this attack
come with me if you want and of course
they do and that's kind of the cool
thing here is when Dan Emmett writes
this when it comes to the character of
Arthur curry well a lot of people may
not necessarily have trust in him he has
faith in himself because Arthur curry
has more often than not been depicted as
an honorable man and it's in that honor
that those who who value honor will
fight alongside him even if it means
fighting to the end because it's better
to die standing than to die on your
knees and so the response is we'll go
with you like we'll fight alongside you
they basically invade where the
Magisters are like the whole nine yards
now everyone's fighting as best they can
mine literally like holding off to the
best of their ability but Aquaman
finally locates the source of the
shield's power and basically goes and
attacks the whole thing now the problem
with this is that he's basically
surrounded by like all these magic
wielders and for the most part hope is
lost
this is literally dan dan dan having it
being like yeah man this is the end all
commands not gonna be able to pull this
off he's just not powerful enough and
it's cool because then he suddenly met
with the arrival of king shark and all
these gang these gang forces of the nine
of the of the ninth tried and it's
really awesome thing here because again
honor it's the most important thing
among these guys Aquaman
knowing he was gonna die led what
members of the undercurrent chose to
follow him into this conflict hopelessly
outnumbered with no real chance of
success and that strikes people who
value honor they look at that and they
say what what kind of person would I be
if I didn't fight alongside them if I
sit on the sidelines like a coward and
just let someone else fight the fight
for me and so King shark along with all
the others all these other guys jump in
they say fine we'll fight too and they
unleash hell on these guys and it ends
pretty quickly with the shield basically
taken down more or less everybody
retreats you know those who survive they
end up retreating Aquaman basically
travels back to the to the to the
widowhood and of course he grabs Mira
and takes off to the surface and that's
where he basically tells Lula you know
again a member of the Atlantean Council
who Stabler who really stayed loyal to
Aquaman who's residing on the surface he
basically tells her looked end after
Mira she's now the queen she's the one
running the show she has to recover she
has to regain you know regain herself
but when that when a time comes and she
returns to Atlantis she'll be running
the whole show at which point Aquaman
jumps back into the ocean it says now
all this left is taking out corm raft
all this left is taking out taking out
the treasonous king it's incredible the
way that it's done and it's beautifully
written but without being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to commerce explain
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
you